[Musique]
m
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur je suis venu vous voir parce
que j
j'ai lu votre annonce ah oui en retrait
vous êtes bien jeunes entreprenants
comme sérieux honnêtement c'est
intelligent modeste bon j'ai besoin
d'affectif
j'avais deviné demoiselles en un sens
oui vous avez lu un roman policier
jusqu'au bout j'ai toujours découvrir
l'assassin avant la fin du quatrième
chapitre mais vous n'avez jamais
vraiment arrêté quelqu'un au non je ne
fréquente que d'honnêtes gens
permettez
c'est la première fois que vous cherchez
une classe de détectives religieuse et
si je ne vous engage pas alors ce
chercheur a une place de cambrioleurs ou
une place d' assassin c'est affreux a
c'est le problème de la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui
voyez-vous ce qui m'ennuie c'est votre
manque d'expérience le vôtre aussi
pourrait l'inquiéter moi je vous avais
dit que je n'avais pas l'expérience
mon petit doigt mais je suis sérieux à
mazet alors vous voyez que je suis venu
vous voir comme ça uniquement parce que
j'ai lu votre petite annonce la jeune
femme seule demande jeune homme
entreprenant pour agence police pour
yves et non non non non je me suis
renseigné
moi je connais votre histoire vous
appeler dominique pourre chartrain vous
étiez institutrice à limoges n'est ce
pas j'étais institutrice à limoges
depuis quatre ans lorsque maurice veau
d'or mourut c'était votre oncle n'est ce
pas il vous a laissé en toute propriété
par testament
cette agence de police privée qu'il a
créé oui à laquelle il a donné son nom
ce qui fait qu'à 28 ans oui mais je sais
aussi votre âge
à 28 ans l'om trouvait la tête d'une
avance de police primés et puis vous les
connaissez absolument rien oui que je
suis pas aussi naïf que sa mine mais
savez vous mademoiselle pourquoi il ya
aucune chaise dans ce bureau
vous ne le savez pas mais moi je vais
vous l'apprendre c'est parce que maurice
fodor votre on avait sûrement pour
devise un pont d'or est toujours debout
c'est bien précis maintenant qu'il était
un génie moselle un véritable génie un
bonheur ne s'assied jamais c'est avec le
temps perdu par les détectives que les
assassins fabrique lamballe ça vous
devriez le savoir je suis votre homme
vous allez mourir
bonjour mes enfants vous ne connaissez
pas mais je suis un vieux clients j'en
ai fait filer des jeunes filles
qu'est ce qui vous amène une jeune
personne précisément qu'est ce que vous
voulez je veux savoir où ils habitent
vous n'avez qu'à le lui demander mais ne
veux pas me dire qu'est ce qu'elle fait
elle et me disent dactylo institutrice
mannequin pharmacienne lycéenne qui
l'âge at-elle une 15 à 15 ans et demi
vieux mâles prendra les filles voilées
quand c'est moi qui vais vous filer si
vous savez je n'en fais tu reviendrais à
savoir choisir ses clients robert
d'ailleurs je vous engage
vous avez de la moralité merci comme
vous avez dit cela si vous touchez à
cette jeune orpheline j'irai le sait le
crédit qu'elle recèle alors vous vous
engagez oui bon alors maintenant boulot
boulot moins facile à dire qu au maroc
ligue 1 juste une femme et son mari une
seule affaire monde sont venus l'un
après l'autre elles voulaient que je
suis reprenne son mari et lui que je
suis sa femme
eh bien je leur ai dit que je ne pouvais
être partout à la fois erreur grave
erreur faudra mettre un peu de papier
dans la corbeille lui donnait
l'impression qu'on travaille dans tous
ces dossiers là rien quelques quittance
profita pas d'après ce nom
mononcle de travail et peu ces derniers
temps bon alors il pourra faudrait
publicité beaucoup de publicité qu'est
ce que vous avez fait dans ce sens là je
tenais là car de la maison au portier de
l'hôtel en face il faut donner la carte
de la maison portier de tous les hôtels
de paris est et pas seulement aux portes
il faut tandem garçon d'ascenseur mais
on se méfie parfois l'inconscience méfie
jamais les garçons d'ascenseur et sur
les murs
qu'est ce que vous comptez m j'ai fait
faire des sous verres la mer de glace le
mont saint michel et une vue climat
pourquoi pas le radeau de la méduse la
mer de glace de ma famille j'ai misé par
une agence de voyage ici je savais
d'ailleurs que vous allez me dire ça je
l'avais prévu mardi la preuve pour les
murs
regardez voilà le petit gabriel deux ans
et demi si tristes hier sig est
aujourd'hui parce que nous l'avons
arracher à ces odieux ravisseurs pour
petits voyeurs et punaise à la poche
gauche du plantage cher si gabriel la
voilà et voici maintenant la jeune
madeleine t 17 ans que son tuteur
avaient séquestré la bande et livrer les
punaises dans la poche gauche dure sa
nouvelle serait devenu une bête une
esclave elle le doit à sa jeunesse son
avenir c'est horrible aussi horrible utt
l'histoire de ce vieillard si vous
mademoiselle oit oui vous si vous
n'aviez pas personnellement déjouer les
sombres desseins de ses héritiers les
punaises bon jeu costume pantalon qu'il
voulait l'empoisonner
comme un rat quel que soit votre âge
lagence veau d'or vous protégera mais il
n'y a rien de vrai dans tout ça nous
n'avons pas ciblé tous ces gens là voilà
je vous attendais ce qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui le sera demain demain nous
arracherons le petit gabriela seijas du
ravisseur est sûre vieillard à une mort
prématurée
demain dès demain nous découvrirons la
cachette de l'achat de matelas ni té
travers cet extra toujours de grosses
sommes près tout seulement il faut venir
nous trouver
les gérants de bénédicte deviendront ils
se marièrent et eurent beaucoup de
clients toujours débout naturellement
vous n'avez pas de carte de france
j'aurais juré je l'avais prévu la preuve
comment voulez vous savoir exactement où
se trouveraient des teens si vous n'avez
pas une gare de france que je n'ai qu'un
détective robert c'est vous il faut pas
le dire j'avais au moins quatre et des
cloîtres et punaises sont dans la poche
gauche de votre pantalon
robert c'est vrai merci dominique briois
savoir exactement où se trouvent vos 80
des vives
si vous n'avez pas les petits drapeaux
fo de la méthode et de la sûreté hayon
faire jacques notamment des granges
hautacam nicolas ta cagnotte kényane
eric daniels s'est pas sur la carte
enfin ça doit se trouver quelque part
par là quant à bagard il est à paris
voilà ça c'est une maison qui
travaillent mais les clients c'est
facile aux pires métiers seront il
faudrait qu'ils étaient les gens il se
positionne dominique vous êtes mariés
vous promener tout seul dans la rue
qu'est ce que vous faites
je regarde les vitrines bon si dans une
vitrine à côté de la plus jolie robe
vous voyez une petite affiche qui vous
demande madame que fait votre mari en ce
moment si vous ne le savez par
l'agencement d'or on le dira mais s'ils
ne font rien de mal lorna
alors vous en soit pour nos frères mais
ça arrive à une fois sur 10 si vous
croyez j'en suis sûr
ces ions toujours vous êtes indien
toujours debout monsieur police oui
monsieur police privée détective badia
discrétion assurée haute moralité
quel que soit votre âge lagence faudra
vous protégera ne cherchez pas vous
asseoir
y'a pas de chaise ici toujours debout
qu'est ce qu'il ya pour vous servir
mais je vous parler le français
on peut c'est à propos d'une femme
oui et les plus longues nous devons
propos retrait dominique c'est de votre
femme qu'il s'agit oui c'était ma femme
elle vous acquittez 1
elle est partie non non il est là mais
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète alors une
lettre elle a dû recevoir une lettre
probablement une lettre anonyme oui une
lettre anonyme mais masse et a dit
recevoir une lettre de menace c'est plus
que probable
vous avez la lettre sur vous oui
demain tu seras morte intéressante
celui qui a écrit cette lettre sur mon
amie de sa femme
pourquoi demain tu seras morte il a tu
toi quand avez vous reçu cette lettre
hier dans le soir où habitez-vous là à
l'hôtel georges 6e' depuis longtemps non
voyage de noces
je suis du danemark votre femme est dans
sa chambre en ce moment où l'ue pourquoi
n'est-elle pas venu avec vous elle a dit
non elle n'a pas voulu c'est ça il n'a
pas voulu
c'est madame il fait ils s'aiment
voulez-vous téléphone à l'hôtel georges
de six jours étoiles 44,09 demandé
madame il sen diffic son mari l'a tant
ici je fais demander votre femme venir
merci à l'hôtel georges 6
madame il scène oui
on ne répond pas
elle ne répond pas elle comprend répond
pas alors voir voix
c'est l'agencé nostradamus qui vous a
mariés oui
[Musique]
qui a tué maggie sun c'est la question
que je pose deux jeunes détectives
dominique pontchartrain et robert bayard
elle a mille scène une française mariée
à lannoy était en voyage de noces à
paris elle a été tuée en pleine lune de
miel les furent son corps on a trouvé un
prospectus de lagence nostradamus l'
agence matrimoniale ou les deux jeunes
mariés avaient fait connaissance
pourquoi ce prospectus était-il sur ce
cadavre dominique et robert espère le
savoir bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
non
parfaitement madame marie si madame
[Musique]
mademoiselle le professeur vous êtes
temps après
non
vous êtes jeune mademoiselle mais vous
avez suffisamment vécu pour vous
apercevoir que la plupart des mariages
n'était pas réussi jalousie querelles
mésentente crime parfois sont le lot des
mâles marié s'il se sépare la
prostitution qu est la trame
quant au mari ils sont rejoint renault
il y a des enfants est encore dit malgré
cela vous voulez vous marier et vous
avez raison car vous le savez les astres
qui gouvernent notre destin détermine
aussi votre personnalité plus votre
caractère
ainsi lorsque vous aurez votre retraite
nous saurons à quelle planète nous
devons votre carré 7
ce sera alors pour louer un jeu de
trouver parmi nos clients un homme dont
l'horoscope nous indiquera qu'il est né
sous le signe de l'astre dont vous
convoitez secrètement l'influente cet
homme sera-t-il un prince sera-t-il un
cheminot nous ne savons rien
lagence nostradamus ou garanti le
bonheur il ne vous garantit pas la
fortune mais cela vous êtes égard n'est
ce pas vous même n'êtes pas fortuné le
monsieur je suis dactylo marie angélique
en élite vous allez grandir mademoiselle
chez monsieur saturnin et le directeur
de notre service astrologie saturnin et
si quelqu'un pour nous voulez vous
marier mademoiselle oui monsieur vous
appelez et dominique baya pendant deux
mois cette question 2 quel est votre
date de naissance même 4 février 1922 24
février 1922 par cette voie là c'est la
guerre avec les clientèles s'imagine
toujours que c'est pour sa part la rage
que je leur demande leur date de
naissance
adèle 24 juillet 1920 signe du poisson
on arrive on les passe en 1922 presque
pas eu de poissons cette année la très
bonne année mademoiselle vous rappelez
vous de l'heure de votre naissance et il
devait être 12h45 puisque mon père m'a
toujours dit qu'il était en train de
manger du sou lorsque je suis né
il ne mangeait jamais de chou le soir il
se mettait à table toujours à amie jenny
eh bien maintenant 12h45 mais sans dire
'ne par conséquent nous allons faire
votre horoscope ce sera vite fait les
poissons du produit des camps sont
toujours les plus facile à marier alors
ses fondateurs oui grâce à toi tous les
papiers oui j'ai même eu un extrait de
casier judiciaire sur les conditions
sont toujours les mêmes 28,50 c'est
encore la première année les experts qui
habite le 1er décan et jupiter est bien
avec tout le monde sauf avec ma bien
entendu revenez demain dans quinze à
trente j'aurais établi votre horoscope
si vous voulez entrer le professeur vous
êtes en rouge
monsieur robert parterre date de
naissance 3 avril 1920
merci vous êtes jeune monsieur mais vous
avez suffisamment des coudes pour vous
apercevoir que la plupart des mariages
n'était pas réussi jalousie querelles
mésentente karine parfois sont le lot
des mariés
s'il ne faisait pas la prostitution qu
est la femme quant à l'epo il tombe dans
libre non s'il y a des enfants
c'est encore pire malgré cela vous
voulez vous marier et vous avez raison
s'il n'est pas le résultat d'une
démarche intéressée
le mariage peut être oui excusez moi
[Musique]
je vous le disais le mariage peut être
heureux car vous le savez les astres qui
gouvernent notre destin détermine aussi
notre caractère plus notre personnalité
ainsi lorsque nous aurons établi votre
horoscope nous serons à quelle planète
nous devons votre personnalité ce sera
alors pour nous un jeu de trouver parmi
nos clients un homme une femme dans
l'horoscope nous apprendra qu'elle est
née sous le signe de l'astre donc vous
convoitez secrètement l'influent cette
femme sera telle une princesse sera
t-elle un cheminot une cantinière nous
n'en savons rien lagence nostradamus ou
garantit pas le bonheur
elle ne vous garantit pas d'un fortement
mais cela vous est égal n'est ce pas
vous même n'êtes pas portugais
non monsieur je travaille à la radio par
faye g votre nom je nomme votre date de
naissance je vais y rétablir votre
horoscope tout de suite
mouvement vers 15h30
je crois que j patrie
[Musique]
à
pourquoi un prospectus de lagence
nostradamus at il été trouvé sur le
cadavre de malamine hussein malla mille
scène qui a été tué en pleine lune de
miel et à kiel agence nostradamus avait
procuré son mari deux jeunes détectives
dominique pontchartrain et robert bayard
mène l'enquêté mais ils amènent chacun
de leur côté
or sans le savoir ils ont eu la même
idée pour découvrir les secrets de
lagence nostradamus
ils se sont fait passer l'un et l'autre
pour des jeunes gens à marier le
professeur cas les a reçus séparément
saturn a établi leur horoscope et c'est
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont rendez vous avec
l'amour
[Musique]
a télé vous
j'allais pas un peu timide
est-ce que je vous plais
vous êtes presque aussi jolie que ma
mère
[Musique]
retrouvez
avec nous il devient votre femme mais je
me serai fidèle vous savez je peux
toucher la mène
en menant à une robe
parce que les astres vous à nous pour
épouse catherine hermary faveur du
climat
tu es là devant une dent type on
aperçoit n'y est que tu n'as pas honte
d'avoir une dent comme ça perdu mes
doigts et mes cheveux non mais regardez
j'ai dû lui poser vos commissions
passaient et mes filles tu as fais mais
je suis parti mais j'ai bon pied et j'ai
beau noël
et puis s'il veut dire passer aux essais
chez vous allez bien
hackett matt encore une de ses élèves
qui t'a reconnu le bouton une bonne
arrière déficit aurait confessé qu'ils
avaient besoin
ça c'est bien ça va ça vient ça tape
eagles à le faire du cinéma
cela est regardée par les hommes ce
qu'elle se mesurer la taille la salle
bousculé dans le métro et ben moi sur
l'autel bousculé dans le métro et de qui
parlez-vous la mijaurée cutter cogito
bouton mon petit ton au dessus moi je
suis soucieux de bennis je suis belle
sans qu'on en parlait je ne me fie
qu'aux parents croyaient vraiment nous
allons nous marier
c'est notre destin vous croyez vraiment
que nous allons nous marier
c'est notre destinée c'est une erreur
une erreur ridicule c'est toujours la
même chose ici on a mis les taureaux
avec les scorpions et les béliers avec
des poissons
quel gâchis c'est toujours la même chose
ici dans ce qu'il fait ou bien de quoi
ça allait ces gens là ont l'air et
trophées pour aller ensemble
abb avec un poisson s'est élancé de
boulleville tous les belges y sont
femmes son nom d'un certain nombre de
scènes il ya énormément de béziers sète
abena ta foi ils sont tous des bibles et
d'une timidité excessive
voilà deux partitions qu'il faut
s'attendre quand j'ai dit regardez
madame men est aussi dispersion
soulignent dit vous ne voyez pas qu'ils
sont faits l'un pour l'autre
tout y est mais à charmant petit payer
voici celle que les astronomes pour
épouser les enfants les planètes ne
manque jamais de faits pour vivre
ensemble de ces pour travailler ensemble
je voulais
pareil on ne savait pas que vous étiez a
promis chance avait rien alors nous
avons eu la même idée
oui oui d'ailleurs se faire passer pour
un tenir lorsqu'on veut surveiller une
agence n'a jamais été une idée géniale
nom et que vous les couvrir nous étions
faits pour vivre ensemble et puis j'ai
surpris les professeurs car qu'est-ce
qui faisait mal eh bien il disait à une
jolie blonde alors c'est entendu 50 50
la première année 40 60 la seconde et la
troisième a mis le divorce à vos frais
il n'allait 10 aces contre le mariage
penser des classiques succès assuré
on fêtait plus à monsieur richard une
petite poule et c'est la petite poule
qui paient les impôts du professeur
parfait mais le problème le problème
c'est de savoir quel rapport il ya entre
l'escroquerie et le crémant jeune
professeur k soit un escroc n'explique
pas pourquoi le meurtrier a posé sur le
corps de la femme des bas noirs
un prospectus de lagence nostradamus
vous allez nous laisser tranquille vous
a déniché atteint oui je n'ai pas peur
je suis là vous voyez bien voulu faire
peur
nous sommes les inspecteurs et puis
après connaissez vous monsieur emile
faber faber
non monsieur non plus il connaît pas
monsieur savard vous voyez bien que nous
ne connaissons pas mais tout ça paie
merci et tout ce que nous voulions
savoir après mon père dans polisse c'est
dedans
connaissez vous monsieur emile faber
faber
non non merci c'est tout
mais pourquoi nous demander où sa faveur
impossible de près et il mort d'un pavé
l'alphabet qui lui a brisé les reins
pourquoi nous demandez vous si nous ne
connaissons pas ce qu'on a trouvé sur le
cadavre prospectus de l'agencé vous
comprenez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]